[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh, hey.
Are you lost?
Hi, how are you?
Oh, come here.
Come here.
Let's have a look at you.
Oh hi.
What have we here?
You've got a QR
code on your collar.
Wow, high tech dog.
So let's see.
Let's scan that.
So your name is Cheyenne.
Hi, Cheyenne.
How are you?
And wow, we got your
mommy and daddy's address,
so you're not going to be lost.
We can find your way home.
And you got a website?
You've got a favorite TV show?
You like "Defiance"?
Yeah, I like "Defiance"
too, but don't tell anybody.
I got a thing for Stahma.
And what's this?
Dog gets homicidally crazy
when it sees the color red?
Oh, stacko!
[GROWLING]
Barcodes and QR codes can
hold amazing amounts of data.
And having a mobile
device in their pocket
giving access to this
data can be greatly
empowering to your users.
I'm Laurence Moroney.
And I'm here today to talk
about the barcode APIs
that ship with
Google Play services
and how you can use them.
To the untrained eye, you might
think that there are really
only two types of barcode, the
one dimensional and the two
dimensional.
But within these, there
are lots of subformats.
And you might find that,
if you roll your own API
or use an off-the-shelf
one, that the format you
need, or you want to
use, isn't supported.
So with the Vision APIs,
we've built support
for lots of different types.
No, I'm not going to
try to say them all.
They typically store
a number, which
could then be used as an ID in
looking up data about an item.
However, with the 2D barcode
types, lots of additional data,
instead of just an
ID can be stored.
And using these, you don't
need domain specific knowledge
to map the ID to some data.
So for example, you could have
a URL, like our lost puppy had.
And that URL can be a website
with data about the item
that you're tagging.
It can be a link to
an app in the store.
It can really be anything
you want it to be.
And by the way, as you've
been watching this video,
some QR codes of
"valuable extra features"
have been popping up at
the bottom of the screen.
Check them out.
Indeed, when using
QR codes in PDF 417,
you have lots of data
types that they can store.
Here's just a few.
You've got URL, contact info,
calendar event, email, phone,
SMS, Wi-Fi, geolocation,
even driver's license.
And to use this in code
is very, very simple.
You just create a
barcode detector.
And you use a builder to
build that for your context.
Now by default, it will look
for the major types of barcodes
that are shown here.
You don't need to explicitly
set a barcode type.
The barcode detector is smart
enough to manage it itself.
But if you do want to set a
specific format to be detected,
the detector has a
set format method
that allows you to do this.
When it detects a
barcode, it will return
a barcode graphic object.
And methods on
this will allow you
to draw the bounding
box for your barcode
as well as a preview
of its value.
When using the Vision
API barcode detection,
the orientation
doesn't even matter.
So you can read your
barcode if it's like this
or even like this.
Now also, importantly,
all barcode interpretation
is done locally, so it's
really fast, not requiring
round trips to any server.
Accessing data in the barcode is
as simple as reading a property
on the barcode object.
So for example, to get the
little lost puppy's website,
I was simply able to use
barcode.urlbookmark property
as shown here.
And that's how simple it is
to use barcodes in your app
with the Vision API.
You can start programming for
this today with Google Play
services on Android.
You can find more details
on the Google Developer site
at the link shown here.
Thank you, and don't forget
to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]